I just remember him like picking up this
kid who was a bully and I just picked
him up and just tossed him down the hall
and that kind of like yeah that was that
was a nice moment yeah and then they
bullied that kid for being again
and no pulse no pulse
[Music]
all right another one for you parents
God damn it can I not be a parent for
once I'm so old hey Geo being a parent
is a 24 7 shot
damn it you're so annoying Speak Your
Truth she gets it she gets it speak your
truth Daddy done
you're so annoying that 24 7. where are
your kids right now with my wife tell
her also that it's cool tell her it's a
thankless job too I'll find a way to
squeeze it later all right so uh let me
know what you think of this new idea
okay there's a Brazilian state that is
the first place ever to issue free
plastic surgery to kids who are being
bullied for physical features no
absolutely not
parent number two I think it's totally
ethical
doing plastic surgery to kids is
probably the best time to do it
so it's not
I just can't even this isn't plastic
surgery like the kind that we are seeing
our peers get this is like uh very like
if if a kid is born with something weird
you [__]
ing [__] [__] how do you set me up
like that that was gonna be my question
too I was like no it's like if a kid is
born with like some kind of funny thing
on their head and they get made fun of
so it's it's things like that what's a
funny thing yeah well you make me sound
like a dick
then yeah I'm for it I don't know but
that's like more like a corrective
surgery it's not really like yeah it's
not but still it's still plastic surgery
what if a kid has like because of
genetics they have like really thin lips
and they need to get like a lip color
genetics well good thing they're in
Brazil
and they're just like
[Laughter]
like what if Ryan just come on hear me
you still want to beat me up
like holy [__] well no you know what you
do
your stance does have a point because
most people have your opinion because
they don't believe that that is the
answer to bullying I don't think it is
because if you're being bullied and you
fix the thing you're still gonna get
bullied the bullying me doesn't stop
bullying that kid no yeah it gets worse
it's like uh well okay so if if whatever
features or deformity or whatever they
have it's not interrupting with their
quality of life
like the actual quality of life like I
don't care about the bullying or
whatever because we've all been bullied
we're all gonna get bullied that's just
what happens this happens
um then I wouldn't be for it okay but if
it's one of those things where they have
like a fetus hanger
you think they should keep it you know
the only thing they should get it
changed if they have like a fetus if
it's if it's messing with their life
right like they can't
a roller coaster
[Laughter]
yeah the number one issue for kids
fun what about like I mean
psychologically as a kid like we're the
kids are so impressionable and they they
are you know observant of what other
kids look like so it's like yes it's to
The Bullying aspect but also like if it
makes the kid feel more included because
they look more normal but then wouldn't
you want to teach them no totally that
yes but also like do you also want your
child to have like the same
opportunities in the way that they would
be treated you know unfortunately with
the society and how people usually think
yeah for sure so I was born
so why
okay we'll wait do you have to pee no I
just have a question oh so I was born
with three teeth right like three front
teeth so when I was like seven
[Laughter]
I'm still trying to heal you [__] you
were so you were born you were born with
three yeah so I was born with three
teeth oh sorry oh three
um so I think when I was like five or
seven or something maybe you pulled it
out right so because they pulled it out
that middle one I had gap teeth okay
don't even matter
[Laughter]
yeah I straightened them out
with braces I remember my mom saying
like yeah we should you should get
braces because then yeah she was kind of
uh uh like going down the path of saying
like yeah man like everything is in a
smile you know so she's like yeah you
should probably get braces and I wasn't
even thinking braces until she was like
yeah like you should have great teeth
braces is cosmetic it is it's all
Cosmetics you know it's still under kind
of like the same tier 100
years
is that is that overkill for like a kid
uh that kid's got some white teeth
because if we're talking plastic surgery
let's say like he needs it now he needs
good teeth this year his adult-sized
yeah and they shave his teeth down they
put like veneers is that like is that
going too far for a kid do you think uh
for me I would say yes that is going too
far because it's unnecessary she hasn't
lost all of his teeth yet you know that
veneer's just gonna come out
yeah
with the teeth on top of the teeth yeah
I can't believe you look like like that
it's not ideal the dentist is pretty hot
right it's like a must do kind of thing
do you see a kid with teeth on top of
it's hot right no I said he was good
explain yourself in the future in the
future
what was your burning questions
yeah what was your question Nick what
was your question I couldn't let it go
it was it was in reference to when
Colleen was talking and I was gonna ask
you were you bullied a lot growing up
was I bullied yeah yeah because I want
to I want to figure out what her pain
points are so I can press on them a
little bit more now that I know that
that's your angle I'm not going to tell
you
were you bullied alive yeah I was
popular what were cute what would kids
bully you about
[Music]
both my brother and I really yeah and
then when it got to high school like my
brother actually started fighting and
like bodybuilding and stuff like that
um I just remember him like picking up
this kid who was a bully and I just
picked him up and just tossed him down
the hall and that kind of like yeah that
was that was a nice moment yeah and then
they bullied that kid for being yeah
and no pulse no pulse
[Laughter]
you were supposed to tell him he's gonna
use it again no it's okay I mean I can't
use those things on you now that's right
I know those are cool qualities though I
can't say you're shy or something I'm so
shy it's not as good you know something
that's more effective than letting your
kid change the way they look because
they're being bullied is just teaching
them how to handle bullies like mentally
instead of going oh you should fix
yourself to counteract the bullies but
remember those kids in school that is
great and I remembered those kids in
school but they got bullied for being so
[__] weird and like having that
Shield like they were just so weird
because they were like acting like
adults no no I think he's talking about
like actual handling of bullies yeah
yeah like how to deal with it when
you're being bullied like mentally like
how can you think differently to to
where that bullying completely doesn't
even affect you anymore because you you
know what I mean yeah yeah I know
exactly so some of the best roast
comedians I know was because they got
roasted yeah so they didn't have the
tools but once they knew how to Dish it
back like that the police were like oh
[__] so now you're bullying the bullies
so the bully never stops
in their adult years I don't think kids
ever fully master that so it's just like
you're just teaching them to think
differently and how to handle the
bullies differently instead of fixing
something about uh your look to go so
how would you stop
I don't know it depends on the situation
well because I know that when my what my
dad taught me was he said if everyone
anyone ever messes with you like don't
do it back to them because then it makes
you become them so for me I I would just
either if I get bullied I would just
either tell an adult or do something
you're a tattletail bro oh don't do that
don't do that'll tell you Dad
yes no but it's either that or or
another thing that he would teach is
like okay you gotta think about why
they're bullying you in the first place
maybe something's wrong with them in
their family in their household so and
that's really mature though that is you
build empathy towards a person bullying
you and you're just like oh man I kind
of feel a little sad instead of like oh
man they're really picking me because
you don't want to ever feel like you're
the problem and they're bullying you
because of your own problem so you have
to figure you have to think in a way
where like no you're totally fine like
you you tell your kid hey it's not you
there's nothing wrong with you they're
just going through and then at your age
you receive that info and processed it
um that's pretty that's crazy okay was
doing mushrooms back then
but the thing is you don't really get
bullied until what elementary middle
school because that's when I started
getting bullied or are you getting
bullied
big small being different because I was
like the only Asian kid like stuff like
that the Garden Grove uh no I I went to
Gardena actually yeah yeah yeah so
anyway like I knew they were bullying me
about stuff that I couldn't change about
myself like I can't just your size yeah
yeah like I'm that's so mature though it
really is yeah and what I learned was
like dude these kids are just stupid
they're just saying dumb [__] that they
don't even realize how it's affecting
other people so I'm just like that is
the most mature thing just bully just
bully me but just know that it's gonna
go in one ear out the other and if it's
like physical that was a nice dancer
yeah you didn't have to get all [__]
because like because once a kid starts
like punching you and beating you up you
don't fight back because then you're in
the wrong too yes that's legally excuse
me
they were like big Believers of like if
you hurt them it's like the same thing
kind of you you're also you're solving
violence with more violence and that's
kind of like the bigger lesson so they
tell you to always exit the exit the
situation like teacher this guy just
straight up hit me right now but luckily
that's never happened to where I had to
like tell you know whatever I never
gotten like physically beat up oh that's
good though because it could have been
when I was a kid I was brutally
um bullied by a bunch of girls
them too why is it brutally because like
it was I was like fourth fifth grade and
they would like chase me around school
like a very recess and then be like
Dumbo Dumbo and they would just like
chase me around and I would come home
like crying and [__] right and they pull
their ears and they and I'd be like like
I'll just be like running and they'd be
chasing my girls bro I got bullied by
girls they liked you bro maybe probably
not so I would go home and then I'd be
like I would tell my mom I'd be crying
about it and she would just tell this is
what she would tell me she's like
they're stupid they're dumb they're just
jealous they're just jealous so then the
next day yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
I'd be like and I would be like oh yeah
you guys are jealous and then they look
at me and go
I'm able to start laughing and then I
was like I feel so empowered I feel so I
feel so ready to take on the world
and then what made them stop I don't
know I don't remember I really don't
remember but I would get i'll dude I was
getting bullied by like [__]
everybody
I was getting bullied for being Chinese
that was a good one and then um do you
think it would have helped if you got
ear surgery in your major ears no no
okay yeah that was my point no yeah it
taught me like and I would get bullied
through Middle School too and I would
like try to fight back yeah and then I
realized like that wasn't really that
helpful either because everyone was like
this is good this guy's just like mad
all the time like everyone's like this
guy was weird it is funny like when you
bully someone and they get mad that's
part of the funniness yeah so you're
kind of playing into it and then in high
school I learned something yeah I
learned how to be funny and crack jokes
back that's the best and then that's the
best and then it was like fine because I
think a lot of times when people like
true bullies they're just looking for
easy targets yeah so as long as you're
not an easy target yeah and you just
have something yeah that's what I'm
saying you gotta teach your kid how to
react to like these so you should bully
them first yeah no come on
oh you don't believe so you learn how to
weaponize Features so how different do
you think your life would be if they
fixed your ears at like fourth grade I
think I'd be a total wuss dude you think
so I'd be even more of a worse than I am
now 100 no thick skin yeah like I think
I'd learn how to div I developed a lot
thicker skin and I learned how to like
um
just not take things so seriously yeah
yeah but it was it took a while but I'm
glad I did I did it that way because
when they're kids and you're teaching
them to fix their their uh issues and
you're now you're telling your kid you
are an issue yeah you know honestly
that's a good point but if the kid wants
lip filler give them lip filler
they know what they what they know you
don't want you don't want your folds
here okay excuse
here you want it to be smooth I feel
attacked yeah no me too
[Music]